[Musique]
la baguette de pince n'est pas juste de
l'eau de la farine du sel de la levure
c'est beaucoup de gestes qui permettent
la transmission d'un réel savoir-faire
il s'agit de 4 ans de travail pour
inscrire les savoir-faire
artisanaux autour de la baguette de pain
et aussi sa culture au patrimoine
immatériel de l'Unesco j'ai eu la chance
d'être présidente du comité de soutien
la demande des 33000 boulangers de
France et de leur président Dominique en
raclte et donc j'ai suivi ce dossier
depuis son lancement jusqu'à
l'aboutissement une très belle nouvelle
la semaine dernière
[Musique]
cette reconnaissance est très importante
pour les boulangers mais également pour
la France en fait il s'agit de préserver
tous les gestes qui sont qui existent
autour de la baguette tous les
savoir-faire que l'on transmet de
génération en génération il s'agit aussi
d'un écosystème autour du métier de
boulanger je le rappelle autant de
boulangeries à peu près que de communes
en France un lieu où le lien social
perdu dans des endroits où parfois il
n'y a plus beaucoup de commerces et puis
également toute la notion de
transmission autour de l'apprentissage
également la notion de culture et puis
aussi ce qui est très important c'est
que la baguette c'est un peu l'ADN de la
France et c'est un sujet de rayonnement
à l'international donc c'est très fort
pour la France sur nos territoires mais
aussi à l'extérieur des frontières
[Musique]